[Music]
and crews from Hell News cause like a
bumpy that's why you don't go Carnival
they're all from Hell which one do you
go I only went Carnival so I already
know I don't even know anything about
this article I'm just saying it's
probably a Carnival cruise we did a
princess princess that's the old
princess like the good ones and a
carnivore the like 18 year old let's get
drunk and like poop off those well dude
there's both on a Carnival cruise it's
young and old but everyone said oh
really
everyone yeah well you know everyone was
like old as hell like they had like
oxygen tanks and [__] [__] walkers
but when that YMCA came on everyone was
like I think old people were partying
harder than us they were that was a nice
cruise Oh free pizza yeah heard princess
is good we had a we had a they had a
pizza bar at ours too and it was like
was it good though no that was the lid
it was it was we'll go next time I just
gamble every day oh yeah we did that was
the best part of it yeah I'll do that
and I found out what sealegs was for the
first time yeah me too oh [__] it was
nuts man
submitted by hello from Oakland Hello
Baby Raiders a 30 passenger brawl was
captured on video aboard a carnival I
knew it man yeah so you're saying I'm
like did you read ahead I did well karna
was just like notorious for being the
heard trashy yeah best commercials they
make it look so fun I can't want to go
in the waters life yes so on this
Carnival Cruise they left from Australia
to South Pacific on a 10-day cruise and
during this 10-day cruise
apparently there was this really large
family group about 30 people that they
as soon as they got on the boat they
just started [__] everywhere they went
what were they
I'm not sure wait with the usage Raiders
like heaven laughter Raider like Raider
fans no that's submitted by Oakland
Oakland that's a good gas zone that's a
really good guess it could be just right
or they're just Raider fans and next
point because the raver fans are known
to like stab people at the games and
[__] which means it's not even it's like
it doesn't matter what color you are if
you're a Raiders fan you're gonna stab
someone
yeah you're a horrible person yeah ICP
fans what are it was like insane the lot
of the lore is hell yeah yeah so these
this big large family group they kept
starting [__] and so I have a couple
video clips of their brawls oh I can't
wait to see it it's all in one clip you
like that video worldstar
it's pretty fast so here we go pushing
their boats that be big keep fighting on
the cruise
kicking kicking them on and down so
someone's I flying a drone and they're
like what the [__] is that let me zoom
in that's the whole family so that's the
family they kept [__] up another boat
yes that race they look white to me
hey they're probably Patriots fans like
[Laughter]
Mexican okay anyone get started in
Australia probably Australians right
yeah bogans I mean I don't know yeah
those are like the trashy Australians
from Australians are rowdy though
they're pretty rowdy up out of all the
tears awesome they [__] party they
party hard and they like to throw down
and hey [__] there well we went on
this tour and on the last day when
they're supposed to go home one of the
girls boyfriends got arrested because
she laid out like two dudes at the place
and every night their party or hardcore
getting into fights they seem like a
like a bunch of fun-loving people every
Australian I've met I love yeah that's
true I haven't met one I don't like it
but I don't know too many wow that
coming from years of bringing pretty big
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was like just waiting yeah it's like
a finger on the trigger and everything
huh as they're saying one of the brawls
it went on for even 45 minutes good
cardio too
that's enough to like fight take a piss
drink a cup of coffee come back
recharged that's a workout dude a
45-minute fight you think they would
have sounded an alarm or something made
everyone go to the cabins and like to
shut it down kind of thing yeah that
second fight in this video clip I showed
you where there was like a whole bunch
of even the security guards were going
in so much of a dick they were for the
security to have to jump in and actually
fight them 45 amazing of constant
fighting is like like I'd be like hey I
need to check my phone real quick like
um - addicted to my phone yeah like
after five minutes of IT everybody I
mean real quick just one second oh okay
I imagine this family taking shifts like
during the [__] fight and who are
they fighting with just random people or
each other
yeah just random people whoever they saw
cuz one one witness are saying that they
even picked on a 16 year old boy because
they thought he looked at them sandal
being stepped on like not the foot just
the sandwich cuz he disrespected me yeah
that's always the best [__] yeah it's
like hey you bumped into me and you
therefore you disrespected me and
therefore we have to fight how is the
best [__] yeah but the staff on the ship
they're also getting [__] because they
shouldn't of you know also engaged
because there's a in this one video clip
it wasn't in the compilation I showed
you but you could see one of the
security guards like there's this woman
he passes by he goes like this like
about to sock the woman but then he
pushes his no she was just there like
just like what the [__] it could have
been one of those were like all the
family members were jumping into them
like all angles and you're like oh [__]
alright no you're good police you stop
dude that's oh you're safe
ya know and then also they there are
reports that they made all these
passengers that were filming the fights
they went on their phones and deleted
videos so somehow I don't know how this
person was able to like the security
guards or city managers do that for
their celebrity [__] clients so I mean
not to justify and see that that's okay
but I'm like yeah totally a lawsuit
waiting to happen I wonder if they're
trainees security like for the for the
Carnival Cruises like you know how
sometimes when police training they have
all the things pop up and you have to
shoot them right so these guys have to
like punch the bad guy but then like a
woman popped up and he's like the
trainee worked out that's true yeah I
like that so they should have more of
those cuz no one was hurt it's like the
men in black thing you were men in black
the training sequence when like an alien
comes out and then like a woman with a
baby
but then he should have shot the woman
with the baby because what's she doing
out at night don't prejudge me I don't
know that woman could have been could
have been there to fight yeah that's all
scary I'm scared I like cruises because
[__] really goes down there's nowhere to
go you know you're stuck on there with
like third a family of 30 insane people
what do you do here's how great my
Carnival Cruise was so it's like we've
got to we go to like what's the shitty
tournament Oh Barbara
that's real no no it's the Hollywood
Highland of Mexico are they cruises
again yep but tourists traps and like
all this like Ensenada yeah we had the
worst scene so then they take you there
right and then so then now it's kind of
sucked and you know we were doing
tequila in town at one point Nikki
literally got taken from me by a bunch
of [__] dudes with whistles so me and
Nikki and my girlfriend Jess she got
taken to and me and my buddy Joe or like
a little [__] and we're like trying to
get her chick back and there put him on
the bar and they made us try to they
made us do like body shots off of them
they couldn't stop you couldn't stop
them you had it they're like [__] all
right I got sort of one of those things
were was like why if I did stop them I'd
be one of those brothers like yo with
the foot he's like he's trying to give
us shots off the girls right so so the
path of least resistance no big deal we
did the shots off of them and then the
next day on the cruise it's like okay
well what's next you know maybe we're
going a little south a little somewhere
else in Mexico it's like okay guys today
we're going for just a day on the water
mmm and we just sat there yeah sat in
the middle of the [__] ocean yeah
they took us away from Ensenada
it was mumble it unenthusiastically just
de oven or even more you stayed on the
water literally just chilled in the
water and everyone just went in the pool
and just kind of like went to the like
sad salad bar just keep us in port so we
can go off and on or whatever it was no
movement nothing it was insanity doing
it was hella boring yeah I would do a
better cruise I've heard princess is
great and I've heard some other place
some other ones are good my grandma was
like why did you do carnival she's like
you should have asked me cuz she's a
[__] cruise bro yeah she knows all
that [__] people love it no of that
they're the only people buying RVs too
if you notice I want to
you know I want to do road trips in an
RV that's true that you've said all day
man no it's true you know cuz and and
you also start to all of a sudden like
like really patterned shirts gaudiya not
there yet but you will
like like all the [__] light Tommy
Bahama shirts exactly it's your jacket
and to me it's anything to distract from
the face because as you get older see
and just kind of take this pattern is
gonna end up on my couch soon it could
be that's not as bad as I've seen though
I've seen some gaudy [__] like some
brooches and anything to just take your
eye focus away from like what's going on
with your face I think that's my theory
I want that [__] I want I want a Persian
princess bedsheet on my jacket dad look
at what you got to look forward to you
Jess oh yeah I'm submitting this is
royalty yes oh they removed all these
people and then God and then I I found
it kind of interesting do that carnival
they were just apologizing for
everything that happened they're like oh
we're sorry because they were even
telling passengers when that big group
of people were still on the ship that
they should go to their cabins and lock
the doors oh no a ruined vacation I
would just start throwing them overboard
yeah Savannah one by one like we like
our group would just be like no like
let's let's let's start like let's find
like one of them in the group and then
we'll just throw them overboard and
he'll be like it'll be like Viacom you
know like you just trail the their army
yeah and you get one you throw it
overboard and then you just dispersed
like [__] cockroaches when a light
turns on just right and then you [__]
follow him again and in while they're
drunk and fighting grab another one of
those guys throw them overboard would
that be so tight cuz if you're in the
ocean you probably diplomatic immunity
right like your community yeah I
probably telling the Filipino workers I
can you get me like a bunch of [__]
zip ties yeah we'll just slowly zip tie
all the [__] family wherever they are
they will throw them over though that's
why you can gamble cuz you're an
international one yes long as you're in
international waters murder is legal
biggest rule
it's pirates law yeah hi Ritz law yeah
and we're gonna make them walk the plank
that would be that would have been
awesome I like it yeah the carnival
offered a 25% off coupon for their next
trip also or everyone else has done 2010
to make it up to everybody they did a
day on the sea damn on the next trip
that's like I'm never ever cruzi with
Carnival again under like here for the
next trip right next time the pizzas
gonna be free or free you can cut the
line you cut the beats alive you cut the
free beats alive uh-huh okay great all
that shit's good down terrible
[Music]